sur la route les chefs doivent être
prêts à réagir aux imprévus et au casse
tête de l'actualité internationale
les attaques contre les installations
pétrolières saoudiennes se sont invités
dans la campagne
on est très préoccupé par ce qui se
passe au moyen orient et on est en train
de regarder attentivement ce qui va se
passer sur le prix du pétrole
ici au canada il n'est pas normal que
les familles québécoises voir le voient
leur budget être affectés ce matin par
un événement qui n'ont rien à voir avec
notre rôle à jouer comme un gamin pays
c'est de stabiliser les régions ancrage
et la diplomatie
l'occasion pour les chefs de se
positionner en fonction de leur poids g
ou justin trudeau la solution passe par
la réduction de la dépendance au pétrole
nous devons continuer d'investir dans
les alternatives c'est pour ça qu'on est
tellement fier des investissements qu'on
est en train faire sur dans les voitures
électriques message similaire du chef
bloquiste qui ont appel à la fibre
écologique des électeurs québécois
si on faisait la transition vers les
énergies renouvelables on serait moins
dépendant de ces fluctuations là on
serait davantage dépendants de notre
propre énergie de notre propre
technologie sans surprise pour le chef
conservateur
c'est la preuve que le canada doit
compter davantage sur ses propres
ressources énergétiques
la solution épreuve et d'avoir et une
crise énergétique alors qu'on peut
déplacer quitte à augmenter la capacité
de raffinage de brut dans l'est du pays
mais il ya des revenus dans l'agenda et
des plans pour un ex pensionnaire
aucun chef n'a proposé de solution à
court terme pour atténuer les effets de
ces bouleversements internationaux pas
de réponses immédiates pour réduire le
prix à la pompe mais plutôt des visions
plus large pour orienter les décisions
des électeurs à long terme ici louis
blouin radio canada les country en
colombie britannique